merci Dominique Estrosi ça sonne de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élu des
Alpes-Maritimes donc du groupe les
républicains on va parler logement
puisque c'est un dossier que vous suivez
particulièrement mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est toujours la réforme
des retraites et cette 14e journée de
mobilisation hier qui a été la moins
suivie est-ce qu'elle marque selon vous
la fin du match oui je pense je pense
que c'était en quelque sorte la drder le
dernier combat d'ailleurs Laurent Berger
le secrétaire général de la CFDT a été
particulièrement clair il a dit c'est
très certainement la dernière
manifestation contre la réforme des
retraites on a vu que la mobilisation
n'était pas au rendez-vous que bon
nombre de salariés n'ont pas fait grève
que les transports n'ont pas tellement
été embolisés donc effectivement je
pense que la page va être tournée de
toute façon tout le monde s'accorde à le
dire la loi a été votée la loi était
promulguée en revanche je pense qu'il
reste encore du grain à moudre entre les
syndicats et le gouvernement sur un
certain nombre de questions en
particulier peut-être
des seniors les négociations salariales
l'usure professionnelle donc je pense
que de ce point de vue là il y aura
encore une des négociations et très
certainement un dialogue qui ne va pas
être facile à mener entre les syndicats
et le gouvernement qui doit reprendre
selon vous oui bien sûr mais je pense
que tout le monde en a la volonté quand
même vous entendez les syndicats et
l'opposition s'insurgés contre le fait
que demain il y a LeBron Pivet dégaine
probablement l'article 40 sur la
proposition de loi du groupe lot est-ce
que pour vous cela Bafou les droits du
Parlement nous la Constitution elle est
la même pour tout le monde aujourd'hui
il y a un article 40 qui interdit
d'aggraver les charges publiques pour
diminuer les recettes de l'État
l'amendement qui devrait être déposé
pour rétablir l'article 1 fait
manifestement aggraver les charges
publiques même si il y a une
compensation à travers les charges du
tabac on sait que ce n'est pas sérieux
on sait que ces charges du tabac elles
sont déjà réemployées à autre chose donc
effectivement cet amendement en pleine
constitutionnelle et il me semble tout à
fait légitime que la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale le déclare comme
tel et donc que le texte de loi liotte
ne soit pas voté vous redoutez cet après
réforme des retraites est-ce que pour
vous il peut y avoir une crise
institutionnelle une crise démocratique
nous je pense par contre il y a toujours
dans notre pays une colère froide qui
gronde une colère sociale qui est
présente peut-être rentrer par bon
nombre de nos concitoyens qui ne
l'expriment pas encore totalement et je
pense qu'effectivement il faut faire
attention en particulier à la rentrée et
puis il faut voir comment les choses
vont se dérouler mais je pense plus à
cette colère froide qui est assez
inquiétante que véritablement une crise
institutionnelle qui pourrait l'exprimer
comment dans la rue dans les urnes alors
dans les urnes bon il y aura a priori la
prochaine étape ne sera que au mois de
mai 2024 avec des élections européennes
mais je pense qu'on n'est pas à l'abri
effectivement on le voit de nouveau de
d'actes de d'actes de dans la rue mais
aussi peut-être de de violence enfin on
voit bien que tout est à fleur de peau
et donc je crois que c'est très
important que cette négociation se
dialogue reprenne même s'il va être
difficile et très certainement qu'il
n'aboutira pas surtout mais déjà pour
faire un petit peu tomber cette soupape
de sécurité qui aujourd'hui est quand
même présente sur tous les territoires
on va parler du logement et Elisabeth
borne a présenté en début de semaine le
plan du gouvernement pour faire face à
la crise du logement hier au Sénat les
professionnels du logement et deux
ministres étaient auditionné sur le
sujet on va tout ça avec Steve Jordan
[Musique]
bonjour Steve bonjour Yann bonjour
mesdames et sive la commission d'enquête
sur l'efficacité des politiques
publiques en matière de rénovation
énergétique tout ça ça fera oui
commission qui a entamé ses auditions
mois de janvier et qui cherchent à
répondre à une grande question pourquoi
la France ne parvient pas à atteindre
ses objectifs en matière de rénovation
énergétique depuis 2013 un objectif très
clair et fixé 500 000 logements rénovés
par an et d'ici 2025 les radications
complètes dépasseoir thermique alors on
en est très loin il faut rappeler ce
qu'est une passoire thermique ce sont
les logements classés aujourd'hui F ou G
par les DPE les fameux diagnostics de
performance énergétique on parle de 17%
du parc immobilier au total en France et
5 millions 200000 résidences principales
au rythme où on va il faudra donc
rénover un million 600 000 logements par
an d'ici 2025 l'année dernière seulement
000 logements ont été rénovés Oriane
qu'est-ce qui coince c'est la question
que vous avez posé madame la sénatrice
hier aux professionnels de la filière
immobilière premier problème
identifié le grand bazar législatif qui
freine la décision des propriétaires de
rénover écoutez
une loi de programmation de cinq ans
renouvelable 5 ans si vous n'arrivez pas
à valider les choses pour que les
covriers les propriétaires les
locataires comprennent qu'on est sur de
la stabilité on arrivera à rien ça
change tous les ans tous les six mois
tous les trois ans c'est trop ces lois
changeantes créer deux choses 1 de
l'attentisme chez les copropriétaires il
n'est pas rare d'entendre en assemblée
générale les copropriétaires nous dire
d'ici à ce que ça change autant attendre
il est urgent d'attendre autre problème
identifié par les professionnels le
calendrier imposé par le gouvernement en
matière d'interdiction de location on
rappelle qu'à partir de 2025 les
logements loués devront obligatoirement
porter au moins l'étiquette F en matière
de DPE et ça va beaucoup trop vite
écouter
la temporalité de la copropriété n'est
pas celle qui figure et qui pourrait
être exiger par les pouvoirs publics
interdit la location ou frapper
d'indécence des logements qui ne
seraient pas placé j'ai ceux qui
seraient au 1er janvier 2025 et Ève en
2028 suspendent la naissance de ses
logements heart et notamment n'est pas
productif pour le marché locatif au
contraire provoque une attrition de
celui-ci et qui est mauvaise la mauvaise
signal et les professionnels de
l'immobilier ont donc fait valoir leurs
difficultés devant les sénateurs quelle
est la réponse du gouvernement de
ministre était auditionné par la
commission d'enquête hier Christophe
Béchu et Agnès panier ruines au plainte
des professionnels qu'on vient
d'entendre écouter
on sait qu'on a un certain nombre de
transformation qui entraîne des
irritants parce que
elle conduisent à des changements de
comportement ou à des alourdissements de
frais qui fragilisent une partie de nos
concitoyens qui les interroge et qui les
font assimiler la transition écologique
à un prétexte pour augmenter les impôts
pour faire en sorte de restreindre un
certain nombre de liberté si on veut
effectivement atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2050 il faut être sérieux et
donc il faut anticiper ces sujets nous
il nous semble important de poser ce
sujet en se donnant le temps mais en
étant aussi capable de tracer des
perspectives ambitieuses
d'accompagnement de la filière
d'accompagnement des ménages
les contraintes qui pèsent aujourd'hui
sur les professionnels de l'immobilier
qu'on vient d'entendre et que vous avez
auditionné hier c'est contraintes elles
sont trop fortes aujourd'hui
je pense que aujourd'hui tout le monde
s'accorde à dire qu'il faut s'embarquer
dans cette rénovation énergétique des
logements ce qui manque aujourd'hui
c'est d'abord de la confiance de la
confiance pour que nos concitoyens se
disent qu'ils vont avoir la possibilité
de réaliser ses travaux de rénovation
énergétique tant au niveau financier
parce que très souvent ce sont les
travaux qui coûtent très cher mais aussi
qui vont pouvoir être accompagnés tout
au long de leur parcours pour aboutir
enfin à cette rénovation énergétique
alors on a des lois on a une loi qui
aujourd'hui la loi climat et résilience
qui a imposé un calendrier nous l'avons
dénoncé lorsque le texte a été en
discussion au Sénat parce que nous
considérons que ce calendrier
effectivement était beaucoup trop
contraint pour autant il a été adopté
donc il faut se mettre en capacité de
pouvoir le tenir mais il faut alléger
ses contraintes aujourd'hui
alléger en tout cas il faut redonner de
la confiance il faut véritablement mieux
accompagner nos concitoyens et il faut
continuer à autoriser
la rénovation geste par geste parce que
bien évidemment ce à quoi nous
prétendons ce sont des rénovations
performantes qui permettent au logement
de gagner plusieurs étiquettes d'un coup
mais on sait très bien que c'est très
difficile de s'engager sur un parcours
qui peut être de 18 mois 2 ans 3 ans et
donc on a besoin de continuer à dire à
nos concitoyens voilà si vous faites un
premier geste c'est déjà une première
façon de pouvoir réaliser des économies
d'énergie et de lutter contre les gaz à
effet de serre mais vous ne devez pas
vous en arrêtez là et on doit continuer
à les accompagner tout au long de ce
parcours à condition bien évidemment
qu'on arrive aussi à simplifier les
procédures à simplifier des dispositifs
parce qu'aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup
d'aide mais nos concitoyens s'y perdent
il y a un maquis d'aide et on voit bien
que ça peut les décourager de ne pas
faire par contre ce que j'ai pu
constater tout au long de ces auditions
c'est que tout le monde s'accorde à dire
que cette rénovation énergétique c'est
le grand enjeu c'est le grand défi de
demain et qu'il faut néanmoins être
rendez-vous un mot sur le calendrier
parce que à partir de 2025 il y a des
logements qui ne pourront plus être
noués loués vous l'avez dénoncé au Sénat
mais est-ce que ça va aggraver la crise
du logement qui encourt est-ce que ce
calendrier il est compatible avec un
retour de la confiance elle reviendra
pas d'ici 2025 il y a des risques
effectivement que compte tenu du
calendrier qui est mise en place que
l'on voit déjà d'ailleurs apparaître que
des personnes des particuliers des
propriétaires privés retire leur bien du
marché du logement soit directement pour
le vendre parce qu'ils savent qu'ils
n'arriveront pas à réaliser des travaux
de rénovation énergétique dans le temps
imparti c'est le cas mais on va on va
voir à l'avenir comment les choses vont
se passer parce qu'effectivement pour
les passoires thermiques les plus
énergivores c'est 2025 donc c'est demain
et pour celles qui sont F ça sera 2028
donc on voit effectivement et le risque
est de voir une attrition des résidences
principales une baisse de l'offre sur le
marché locatif qui ne va pas ranger
effectivement la crise du logement que
nous connaissons dans notre pays les
abords on a fait des annonces en matière
de rénovation énergétiques 200 000
rénovations en 2024 c'est ce qu'elle a
annoncé ça vous semble assez ambitieux
je veux rappeler les chiffres tout à
l'heure mais 200000 rénovations par an
ça vous paraissait ambitieux un plan
assez ambitieux non on reparlera du
Conseil national de la refondation sur
le logement et de l'ambition qui n'est
pas celle qui est au rendez-vous sur la
rénovation énergétique je vous assure
véritablement dans les annonces de la
première ministre il y a rien de nouveau
alors elle dit qu'effectivement il faut
augmenter le dispositif ma prime rénove
mais uniquement pour les rénovations
performantes celles qui sont les plus
difficiles à conduire et à atteindre
avec des chiffres qui ne sont de toute
façon pas à la hauteur des objectifs
ambitieux tels que la France les a fixés
elle dit qu'il faut mettre des points
France rénovs partout dans les
territoires ce qui commence déjà à se
faire de 450 à 1300 un par
intercommunalité mais c'est déjà en
route si j'ose dire et enfin elle dit
qu'il faut augmenter le nombre de mon
accompagnateur rénov c'est personne qui
vont accompagner le parcours de la
rénovation énergétique auprès des
particuliers depuis la recherche de
financement depuis l'accompagnement
technique et l'accompagnement social cet
accompagnateur rénove va se mettre en
place seulement le premier septembre
aujourd'hui ça manque de garantie de
neutralité et on sait aussi qu'il n'y a
pas forcément les personnes qui seront
formées pour faire ces métiers donc je
ne vois pas comment ce nombre pourra
doubler dans le temps annoncé par la
première ministre vous dites que c'est
pas faisable mais que c'est assez
ambitieux ce que j'essaye de comprendre
ce que vous dit qu'il y a rien de
nouveau en matière de rénovation
énergétique dans les annonces qui ont
été faites on continue
sur ce qu'il y a été fait jusqu'à lors
et donc il n'y a pas l'ambition
nécessaire pour enfin embarquer tout le
monde vers cette massification de la
rénovation énergétique au-delà de la
rénovation énergétique ce plan est les
conclusions de ce conseil national de
leur fondation sur le logement il visait
à facilité l'accession à la propriété on
sait que c'est difficile aujourd'hui
d'accéder à la propriété du coup ça a
des conséquences sur l'accès à la
location et il y a aussi des pénuries de
logements ne fait que le plan
d'Élisabeth borne répond ou à la crise
du logement selon vous écoutez je pense
que vous avez pu lire la presse depuis
48 heures tous les acteurs de
l'immobilier ont eu les mêmes réactions
mépris des illusions déception je crois
que le Conseil national de la
refondation sur le logement aura eu le
mérite de faire l'unanimité contre lui
il y a plus de 200 personnes qui ont
travaillé pendant 7 mois à ce conseil
national de la réfondation tout ça pour
ça pour quelques mesures quelques
mesures techniques quelques mesures
courtes mais qui n'apportent aucune
réponse à la gravité de la du logement
que connaît notre pays et auxquels sont
confrontés les Français je pense encore
une fois mais comme dans la précédente
mandature Emmanuel Macron et ses
gouvernements successifs mais plus
particulièrement depuis un an n'ont pas
pris conscience de la gravité de la
crise du logement non pas les moyens en
face qui permettraient de commencer à
essayer de la résoudre la résoudre sur
tous les marchés du segment du logement
le logement social il est oublié le
logement locatif neuf et le logement
locatif il est en panne l'accession à un
propriétaire n'en parlant plus le
parcours résidentiel ne fonctionne plus
et bien je pense que malheureusement
Emmanuel Macron n'aime pas l'immobilier
le logement n'est pas une priorité pour
ce gouvernement il n'y a aucune ambition
aucune stratégie qu'est-ce qui manque
qu'est-ce que vous attendiez qu'est-ce
que vous auriez aimé qu'Elizabeth bandit
mais je crois qu'il y avait beaucoup de
propositions sur la table qui ont été
faites par tous les acteurs de
l'immobilier des propositions assez
innovantes moi ça fait longtemps que je
plaide pour la mise en place d'un statut
du bailleur privé de considérer que la
personne qui investit dans le logement
elle a un rôle d'utilité sociale de
considérer que un investisseur dans le
logement c'est pas ni un rentier ni un
Thénardier qui va voilà par rapport à
des locataires mais c'est quelqu'un qui
prend des risques qui entreprend mais si
en même temps on encourage pas cet
investissement locatif par des par des
niches fiscales par de la possibilité de
pouvoir avoir plus de revenus pour
pouvoir mieux investir et bien on bloque
le marché de l'investissement locatif
c'est un des exemples d'une proposition
innovante qui était mise sur la table
elle a été balayée d'un revers de la
main parce qu'elle coûterait trop cher
mais c'est toujours la même chose
c'est-à-dire que Emmanuel Macron le
gouvernement de Madame borne voit le
logement uniquement avec une approche
budgétaire et comptable on considère que
la politique du logement en France elle
coûte trop cher on ne dit jamais ce
qu'elle rapporte effectivement c'est 35
milliards de dépenses mais c'est plus de
85 milliards de recettes et ça c'est
malheureusement je dirais le péché
originel depuis qu'Emmanuel Macron est
aux affaires tout le temps on a vu que
rien n'était fait pour le logement à la
hauteur de ce qui doit être fait dans
notre pays un dernier mot puisque hier
en commission vous avez voté contre le
prolongement du plafonnement de la
hausse des loyers ça devait s'arrêter
fin juin le gouvernement souhaitait le
prolonger pourquoi vous avez voté contre
est-ce que dans un contexte d'inflation
vous ne craignez pas que ce soit mal
perçu alors on a voulu d'abord dénoncer
une méthode une méthode d'impréparation
une méthode d'urgence effectivement
cette mesure nous les avions votées dans
la loi de pouvoir d'achat au mois de
juillet dernier donc nous ne sommes pas
contre de telle mesure par contre arrivé
avec une proposition de loi il y a tout
juste dix jours à l'Assemblée nationale
avec des délais qui ne sont pas
respectés alors que le gouvernement
savait très bien que tout s'arrêtait au
30 juin 2023 donc il avait tout loisir
dès le mois de janvier dès le mois de
février de présenter un texte de loi
dont on aurait pu discuter calmement
avec une concertation qui aurait pu
s'engager avec là encore les acteurs qui
ont été pris de cours avec des études
d'impact qui auraient pu être menées et
surtout avec des compensations qui n'ont
pas été prévues dans cette proposition
de loi alors que l'année dernière il y
avait des garanties de compensation et
puis je pense que la situation n'est pas
tout à fait la même que celle que nous
avons vécue au mois de juillet dernier
lorsque ce paquet a été voté la guerre
en Ukraine avait juste commencé
l'inflation était au plus haut la
l'inflation donne quand même quelques
signes de repli et je pense pour revenir
au sujet précédent que si nous voulons
aussi que les propriétaires privés
puissent véritablement s'engager dans
les travaux de rénovation énergétique il
faut qu'ils aient des ressources des
recettes et si on continue à plafonner
leur loyer on y arrivera jamais d'autant
plus que l'État ne donne aucune garantie
financière enfin dans les logements
sociaux ce qui pèse le plus pour le
budget des personnes les plus ce ne sont
pas tant les loyers parce que les loyers
les bailleurs sociaux ne vont jamais au
plafond de ce qu'ils pourraient
appliquer ce qui pèsent le plus ce sont
les charges et sur la question des
charges rien n'est fait rien n'est
proposé merci Steve mais merci à vous
faut revenir tout à l'heure mais
vous-même avec grand plaisir du projet
de loi justice du gouvernement vous
attendez
tout à l'heure
chez vous du côté de Nice on va voir
l'actualité dans votre département on
trouve Denis carro bonjour Denis merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous directeur des
rédactions du groupe Nice Matin et Denis
avec vous on va revenir sur les
incidents à répétition dans le quartier
des Moulins sur fond de trafic de drogue
oui bonjour Oriane bonjour Dominique
Estrosi sessonne alors le effectivement
le quartier des Moulins que Dominique
Estrosi ça sonne connaît bien vider
flambées de violences à répétition
depuis des semaines mercredi dernier
encore une fusillade a fait un blessé
grave à chaque fois le scénario et le
même c'est des guerres de territoire
sans fin sous fonds de trafic de drogue
une situation qui fait craindre une
dérive à la Marseillaise alors ce sont
les mots du préfet des Alpes-Maritimes
Bernard Gonzalez qui a renforcé
considérablement les moyens de police
dans dans le quartier en moins de deux
mois ce sont 250 personnes qui ont été
arrêtées mais 13 seulement ont été
écroués et certains passent carrément
entre les mailles du filet c'est le cas
d'un homme et d'une femme qui ont été
jugés lundi soir par le tribunal de Nice
chez eux la police avait trouvé trois
armes chargées près de 7 kg de cannabis
de la cocaïne 11000 euros en liquide et
ils ont été libérés le tribunal ayant
annulé la procédure alors à leur
rencontre la raison et simple les
policiers n'avaient manifestement pas
demandé l'autorisation de pénétrer dans
les parties communes de l'immeuble au
moulin alors ma question madame la
sénatrice doit-on revoir ce type de
disposition juridique qui au bout du
compte
l'esplaner un sentiment
d'impunité et doit-on renforcer la
réponse pénale pour faire en sorte de
mettre fin réellement au trafic qui
gangrène le quartier des Moulins oui
vous l'avez signalé Denis je connais
bien ce quartier j'ai eu en
responsabilité pendant plus de 20 ans
tout ce qui touche à la politique de la
ville et j'étais conseillère
départementale du quartier des Moulins
je suis effaré de voir combien la
situation s'est dégradée en l'espace de
deux ans mais cette situation qui s'est
dégradée elle n'est quand même pas
propre au quartier des Moulins aussites
malheureusement tous les jours que de
plus en plus ce trafic de drogue ce
capitalisme sauvage qui amène à
conquérir des territoires se répand non
seulement bien sûr dans les quartiers
les plus sensibles mais aussi dans des
villes moyennes ou dans la ruralité et
effectivement je crois que aujourd'hui
pour lutter efficacement contre le
trafic de drogue la police fait son
travail et je soutiens absolument les
forces de sécurité les forces de police
bien sûr qui sont commandés par le
préfet des Alpes-Maritimes et par le
directeur départemental de la sécurité
publique je soutiens également bien sûr
le maire de Nice qui donc s'investit
largement pour faire en sorte que dans
ce quartier on retrouve une vie quasi
normale mais vous l'avez signalé ce qui
pêche aujourd'hui c'est la chaîne pénale
c'est effectivement ce que ne
comprennent pas nos concitoyens c'est
lorsque la police fait son travail les
policiers sont de véritables fantassins
de la lutte contre la drogue et bien
très souvent les dealers qui sont de
plus en plus souvent arrêtés grâce en
particulier aux caméras de vidéos
protection sont relâchés quasi
immédiatement parce que voilà on ne
trouve pas la preuve qui permettait de
montrer qu'il y avait la raison de
pouvoir les incarcérer alors moi quand
j'avais été présidente de Côte d'Azur
Habitat qui est le plus gros bailleur
social et qui est propriétaire de la
quasi totalité des logements social
sociaux pardon dans ce quartier des
Moulins j'avais autorisé effectivement
les forces de police mais aussi tous les
personnes assermentées de pouvoir
rentrer dans les halls d'immeubles
aujourd'hui que je sache c'est tout à
fait possible et permis par la loi à
partir du moment où le bailleur social
ou le copropriétaire la copropriété de
l'immeuble en donne l'autorisation et
l'affiche dans le hall d'immeuble alors
je comprends pas beaucoup cet
argumentation qui a été utilisé dans ce
cas précis auquel vous faites référence
mais je pense que aujourd'hui on ne on
ne vaincra pas cette bataille de trafic
de drogue uniquement à travers bien sûr
l'investissement des policiers il faut
qu'il y ait une réponse pénale mais il
faut aussi qu'il y ait un ensemble de
choses on le voit de plus en plus au
niveau de l'éducation nationale au
niveau de tout ce qui peut se passer en
termes de sensibilisation des publics on
a beaucoup plus de consommateurs de
drogues que l'on en avait par le passé
et la France est aujourd'hui le premier
marché de cannabis en Europe donc tout
cela explique ceci mais explique aussi
comment les dealers se déplacent
investit des territoires qui ne
connaissaient pas jusqu'à lors les
dérives à la Marseillaise auxquelles
vous faites référence mais pour le
quartier des Moulins effectivement je
constate une grande dégradation alors
que beaucoup de choses ont été faites
dans ce quartier mais on doit avoir
qu'une seule préoccupation c'est de
permettre à la plupart des habitants de
ce quartier qui se comportent dignement
de pouvoir continuer à y vivre en
relative sécurité et alors qu'ils ont
peur tous les jours pour leur vie et
pour celle de leurs enfants
Denis
une dernière question oui vous venez de
le dire Madame madame la sénatrice
beaucoup de choses ont été faites dans
le quartier des Moulins comme dans
beaucoup de cités sensibles en France
des dizaines des centaines de millions
ont été investis dans des opérations de
de réabilisateur de réhabilitation de
grande ampleur qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
marché je pense que sur la rénovation
urbaine il n'y a pas eu de véritable
échec d'une part on a agi sur
l'architecture mais aussi on a
accompagné en tout cas Nice toujours
avec des mesures d'accompagnement social
des mesures qui visent à meilleur
insertion sociale et professionnelle des
personnes qui habitent aujourd'hui nous
sommes submergés submergés parce que ce
trafic de drogue je l'ai dit à explosé
submergé aussi parce qu'il est souvent
en lien avec une immigration une
immigration illégale et ce chaos
migratoire il faut bien évidemment
aujourd'hui arriver à le résoudre à y
mettre fin c'est ce qu'a fait ce qu'a
fait le les républicains tant au Sénat
que à l'Assemblée nationale à travers
les projets les propositions de loi que
nous venons de déposer qui font en tout
cas beaucoup réagir qui montrent qu'on
met le doigt sur des mesures qu'il faut
aujourd'hui impérativement prendre dans
notre pays mais je pense que en tant que
tel ce quartier des Moulins il a été
ouvert sur la ville et on lui a amené
les transports et ça relève plus
effectivement de politique nationale au
niveau bien sûr de la justice mais au
niveau aussi du chaos migratoire parce
que je suis désolé il y a un lien
incontestable entre immigration et
délinquance merci Denis carro merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous la une
c'est ce lendemain de manifestations
baroud d'honneur c'est à la Une de
Nice-Matin aujourd'hui merci de nicaro
d'avoir été avec nous et merci beaucoup
Dominique merci beaucoup
pendant cette première demi-heure dans
20 minutes dans le club des territoires
débat sur les moyens de la justice entre
Nelly Bertrand la secrétaire général du
Syndicat de la magistrature et Dominique
Verrien qui rapporte du projet de loi
justice qui est examiné en ce moment
même au Sénat ce sera suivi dans 20
minutes mais d'abord on accueille notre
prochaine invité c'est Olivier Faure qui
nous rejoint